Okay. Welcome back to Gary's Economics.
Today we're going to talk about investment.
This is building on some stuff
we've been talking about about growth.
And there's a question about, okay
how do you get growth?
You need to invest, invest to build your economy.
Invest, invest, invest. Let's grow.
And I think it's important to understand
how does investment work.
Because I think there's a very simplistic
understanding of investment,
which is if you want to invest,
you need to give loads of money to rich people,
because who does investments?
Rich people,
if you give loads of money to rich people,
we’ll get investments and we’ll grow.
If you look at the last 20, 30 years
when the wealth of the rich
has grown really significantly, investment
has actually fallen in many countries,
especially here in the UK.
So why is it that when you give money to rich people,
it doesn't necessarily lead to investment?
But the first thing I would say is
when a rich person invests,
it doesn't necessarily lead to the creation
of new productive capacity.
So for example, if I make £2 million
and I use it to buy all your mum's houses,
it doesn't really do much to improve the economy.
So rich people can simply invest by buying your assets.
And this leads us to thinking
and a little bit
of a more nuanced way about investment.
And for me,
when you want to create investment
to create new productive capacity,
there's basically two things you need.
Yes, you do need somebody
to basically fund that investment,
which is basically I'm going to use the resources
that I have to create something new,
to build something new, to build a new factory,
to build a new windmill,
to build the new diamond mine,
whatever, to build the new office block.
You need somebody
to say, I'm going to provide the resources
and in a modern society,
which is very unequal, that is often the rich.
But, you know, when you look back at the postwar period
when investment was much higher,
it could be government or it could
be, you know, a group of ordinarily non
super wealthy people putting their resources
towards building new things.
But it doesn't just require
people to fund the investment.
You also need profitable investments to exist.
So I have been
essentially retired ten years ago.
And since then
I've basically been living off my investments
and so I guess you could say I'm
a professional investor in a way,
although I think that's probably
a little bit of an excessive
fancy word to say, A rich person.
In that course of time,
I've done loads of different investments
and some of them were like productive investments.
Let's build something, that's create
something new in the economy.
And some of them were,
you know, I'm just going to buy existing assets.
I'm going to buy the stock market, I'm going to buy
gold, I'm going to buy a property.
And in the course of those ten years as an investor,
almost all of the times I tried to invest in actually
building new
productive capacity,
increasing the size of the economy.
I lost money, basically,
those investments almost all failed.
And almost every single time
I just bought stuff that already existed,
I made a ton of money.
The most profitable investment I ever did
was probably buying a ton of gold
at the beginning of Covid.
I made an absolute fortune on that. And,
I think it's pretty clear that me buying
a ton of gold does nothing to help grow the economy.
And this raises the question of
why is it that trying to build new stuff
is not profitable,
but buying existing stuff is profitable?
And I think that is because essentially,
to make a productive investment,
a profitable investment, you need a customer.
At the end of the day it's not enough
just for rich people like me to turn up and say,
here's the money.
You also need businesses to say, well,
we know that there's a massive customer base out there,
so we want to build new stuff for these people.
And I think the story of the last 20, 30 years
is basically the impoverishment of the middle class
and the ordinary British family,
the ordinary American family, European family,
Australian family, whoever you are,
at the expense of the very rich.
And that is why
trying to grow the economy has basically failed.
And if you look at this,
the parts of the economy
that have grown a lot,
it's almost exclusively
luxury stuff and services for the rich.
So I think
this sort of drive towards growth and investment
will not work
unless you deal with the fundamental inequality
that exists in our society.
And that is because
no matter how much money you give to the rich,
when they go to businesses and say, here's
the money, businesses are going to look and say,
well, where is the customer?
And if the only people they see
who are accumulating
a ton of money are very rich people,
even if we do build new productive capacity,
the only stuff they're going to
create is super luxury,
expensive stuff that you can't afford
that is for the rich,
because these guys have the money.
And I think what you need to understand is
a capitalist economy is very flexible.
It will provide stuff
specifically for people who have money.
You know,
I often think, you know,
since I started this YouTube channel, people like to
tell you go and be like Mr. Beast.
For those of you who don't know, Mr. Beast is,
I think, the most biggest, most watched YouTuber ever.
And he does a lot of stuff, like he goes to Africa
and he pays for like cheap
eye surgery for people in sub-Saharan
Africa, in poor communities
and these are very cheap surgeries
that provide extraordinarily, phenomenally
significant improvements
in life for people in poor communities.
So if you think from an investment perspective
like this should be what we're investing in right?
Here are people who,
you don't need to put a lot of money in,
and you can really significantly
improve their quality of life.
So why don't we do that?
Why does capitalism, why do businesses,
not build healthcare in sub-Saharan Africa?
The answer is quite simply
because sub-Saharan Africans are poor
and capitalism
does not provide investment for poor people
because they want it to be profitable.
And the reason you should be worried about
this is because in the West, in the UK,
US, Europe, Australia, increasingly
ordinary people are poor.
You are poor. Your future is poor.
So if you want growth, if you want investment,
you're not going to get it.
Unless you deal with the fundamental fact
that you are poor,
you need to deal with the distribution.
Listen,
capitalism has for a long time not provided
anything for people in sub-Saharan Africa.
People in lots of Latin America, People in lots of Asia
because they were poor people.
And it was easy for
people like us not to worry about it
because we were the comfortable middle class.
Now we are poor. The average British person is poor.
The only way to get things
is to change the distribution.
If you don't change the distribution,
then all of that new investment
will be luxury
consumption, luxury properties, luxury holidays
for the rich and that is not going to help you at all.
So this relates to the videos
you've been doing
about the stupidity of growth,
which is if you focus only on growth
without focusing on distribution,
all you do is keep running
towards slavery at a faster rate.
Listen, there's a fundamental imbalance of power
and resources.
You are in a competition with the rich for resources.
If we're going to invest in this unequal system,
businesses will have a choice.
Are we going to build
healthcare centers in sub-Saharan Africa?
Are we going to build affordable homes
for poor people in the UK,
or are we going to build a sixth
helipad on the top of Elon Musk's f**king skyscraper?
You are going to lose that competition.
As the rich get richer and richer,
they will take the resources
and the investment that you need,
and the economy will turn into an economy
which provides only for them.
I don't know if you've seen The Hunger Games.
They have this city, which has one super luxury center
where all of the rich people live,
living lives of unbelievable luxury,
surrounded by terrible poverty.
Listen, that is what investment
looks like in an unequal society.
The only way to get investment
for you is to get wealth back.
To get power back
from the superrich into the hands of ordinary families.
And the only way to do that is to tax the rich.
And I know I say it millions of times,
and I'll say it millions of times more,
because until we do that,
our society will collapse into poverty.
Taxation is the only way
to escape poverty for your kids and your grandkids.
Tax the rich more, tax working people less.
Save the f**king future. Good luck.